bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt prince alors je le disais
votre cliente contestait la suspension
de son contrat et du versement de son
salaire causés par son refus de se faire
vacciner elle a été déboutée par le
tribunal administratif de versailles
aujourd'hui quel regard portez-vous sur
cette décision de justice
une grande tristesse une grande
tristesse parce que j'ai l'impression
que justice n'a pas été rendue le
tribunal déboute ma cliente uniquement
sur le fait qu' il n'y avait pas urgence
à statuer sur son dossier sur soudain et
pour rajouter la justice à la justice
le tribunal reproche à ma cliente est à
l'origine du problème en fait il a put à
ma cliente le fait d'avoir refusé de
s'être fait vacciner
c'est à mon sens très grave
d'abord parce qu'il ya un déni de
justice on demandait aux juges de
statuer sur la pertinence de nos
arguments le juge battant touche tout ce
que l'on a développé comme argumentation
et nous dit en fait il n'y a pas
d'urgence
cela veut dire quoi cela veut dire que
l'on accepte qu'une personne ne touche
pas de salaire ne puisse pas travailler
soit suspendu et cela à durée
indéterminée vous rendez bien compte que
une personne comme ma cliente qui touche
un salaire
très moyen très moyen prix lui permet à
peine de vivre ne va pas pouvoir tenir
longtemps c'est plus une décision de
justice ce n'est plus une décision
parlementaire cela devient du chantage à
la vaccination et si cela concernait
tous les français je me serais pas
offusqué si cela si le juge avait statué
sur nos moyens je ne serai pas offusquer
mais de là à nous dégoûter sans
consistance je n'arrive pas à comprendre
pour moi il y a une forme de déni de
justice excusez-moi d'employer un terme
aussi fort
en imputant à ma cliente la faute de ne
pas s'être fait vacciner c'est comme si
on disait
excusez moi aussi de la comparaison à
une personne qui vient de subir des
violences sexuelles c'est de votre faute
il fallait pas porter une mini jupe
justement le siège est sis le juge
explique que la perte de la rémunération
de la salariée est liée à son refus de
se soumettre à la loi que répondez-vous
à cela également
nous avons contesté le changement
constitutionnel de la loi alors en
voyant des gars très simple la loi pour
nous ne répond pas aux obligations
inscrites dans la constitution
on a déposé pour cela une qpc excusez
moi des termes techniques c'est une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité c'est à dire que ma
cliente dit la loi n'est pas conforme à
la constitution et le conseil
constitutionnel qui s'est prononcée le 5
août 2000 21 à 10 les sénateurs qui nous
ont saisis pour nous donc pour nous
demander notre avis sur le la
constitutionnalité de la loi imposant le
pass sanitaires
noomiz a pas saisies sur l'obligation
vaccinale c'est qu'il ya un problème
l'obligation vaccinale pose problème
d'abord parce que on ne peut pas
considérer aujourd'hui que les vaccins
qui sont ni sur les marchés
détiennent la dénomination de vaccins
simplement parce que ils ne sont pas
encore ils n'ont pas subi tous les
stades des tests in en sont au stade à
la phase iii des tests et que la fin des
tests des produits que tout le monde a
dans son corps par injection n'aura lieu
qu'en 2023 pour certains d'entre eux
sinon 2025 m nous ne manquons pas faire
non concernant christelle ses skis vais
avoir d'autres jeux d'autres poursuites
d'autres suites judiciaires pardon après
cette décision ok qu'est ce que quels
sont les plans alors on a déposé quatre
demandes particulières
la première demande
c'est une requête en référé c'est à dire
on a dit ouf il y a urgence à statuer à
statuer pas ne pas statuer à statuer et
le juge nous a débouté en disant que
c'est de la faute de ma cliente qui
serait elle même dans cette situation
très bien mais ce n'était pas tout on a
déposé aussi une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité il le juge a refusé
de statuer sur cette question
rappelez-vous le terme que j'ai employé
prioritaires prioritaire or le juge
ballom la priorité est dit y a pas
urgence on verra ça par la suite on
laisse les gens mourir de faim on laisse
les gens ne plus travailler on laisse
les gens ne plus avoir de salaire on
verra plus tard quand plus tard on n'en
sait rien j'épouse est aussi une
question préjudicielle au juge des
référés question préjudicielle j'ai
demandé au juge des référés de demander
à l'europe cour de justice de l'union
européenne
si la loi imposée en france et est
compatible avec les textes européens qui
disent il faut en aucun cas forcer les
citoyens à se faire vacciner ce n'est
pas une obligation donc là l'oural
aurait pu dire le passé ni terre pour
tout le monde on ne discute pas dans le
passé ni terre il y à des tests on ne
discute pas mais imposer à une catégorie
socioprofessionnelle des vaccins je
trouve que c'est extrêmement choquant on
en est réduit on hamm est aujourd'hui à
l'immunité
vaccinale on est à 50 millions sur 67
millions on dit que il y a il n'ya plus
que neuf millions de personnes qui
notera reçu une première dose si on
croit ce qu'a dit l'institut pasteur on
est au delà des 80 % qui nous permet à
toute la population française de
bénéficier d'une immunité jackson m v6
se sont sont rentrés dans les analyses
médicales aujourd'hui ce qu'on a envie
de savoir ce qu'est ce que va devenir
christelle ces professionnels manquer ce
qui va lui arriver comment est-ce
qu'elle envisage l'avenir
sur le plan judiciaire on va être obligé
de saisir le conseil d'état en procédure
d'urgence
référé liberté devant le conseil d'état
qui est l'autorité suprême de notre pays
mais si tu as un scoop je viens de
raccrocher avec une auto respondents
internationale on va dans la foulée
déposer un recours devant le comité des
droits de l'homme halloween
voilà où en sont les recours aujourd'hui
merci roger rb6 d'avoir répondu à nos
questions bon courage à vous je rappelle
que vous êtes l'avocat de christelle
c'est vous êtes spécialisé dans le droit
pénal médical responsabilité médicale et
dentaire et procédures disciplinaires
merci à vous